it sounds like the workload of making
that app must be huge so they modeled
mobility wad on pornhub i think
originally because who better who else
has got lots of videos that need like
tagging and filtering and categorizing
so like the original mod website when it
first got launched was based on that and
they're just going to see
when you go stretching you can say like
brazilian bbw
exactly
johnny and youssef welcome to the show
this is a really exciting one why
because it's the first time we've got
proper
setups we're not just using a potato
you're not beating it as much as you
used to yeah this is hd hacks
hd potato
that's it man
better potato if you're not used to life
hacks we go through tools techniques and
tactics for a productive and efficient
life and then the other two people
tear it down or say that it's amazing
and immediately acclaim that person as
the new victor uh we'll get through
whatever it is that we have chance to
see today and then maybe time for some
things that have been watching netflix's
stuff
at the end
and
as is tradition
uh
johan sebastian there's a hot potato
caught it what have you got i have
caught it
so
my life hacks today
are
as a result of having
done a version of
75 hard at the start of this year
so if people aren't familiar with that
it is a
largely stupid
idea where you do lots of training and
drink lots of water and do lots of very
difficult things for 75 days in a row
and if you skip a day you have to go
back to day one again so as you can
imagine skipping a day is fairly bad
news
um so one of our friends was going to do
it he did the proper version i did like
a scaled back version but i ended up
having to do loads of habits very
consistently that i've not
you know without skipping a day so lots
of kind of efficiencies and hacks as it
were
have you got the full list of the
official 75 hard
i don't but i i'm worried that'll derail
things okay you know i want to get to
the to the meat
so one of the things that i did every
day was
uh just take my supplements every day
which is something that we probably all
do with like decent consistency
i found that made it really easy to do
i'm not really sure how you two are
going to react to this
i ordered some
apple cider vinegar
and some collagen
from my protein in the form of a
like a chewy gummy
okay
okay
i'm not i'm not offended so far
okay it's all going well so far so that
the hack is
the hack is
have one supplement that you take per
day
that's a sweetie that's a gummy so like
let's say you're going to take a
multivitamin or vitamin d
or something else just my protein
basically make everything at this point
in the form of a gummy
and it's just like having sweets so what
how does that help you
stay compliant with the rest of your
supplements
it's just the standard habit formation
multivitamin gummies yeah
flavor that's what you said
it always sounds like i'm plugging my
protein like this is this is legit like
i tried them they taste really nice the
apple cider vinegar and the collagen
ones i have very specific reasons for
the collagen ones the apple cider
vinegar ones just sounded nice how much
yeah it's collagen gummies
yeah
how much gummy do you need to eat in
order to get an even close to
like
are you imagining like a big gummy that
comes in a tube and you say i've got a
tub of i've got a tub of collagen
protein over the far side
got it
and yeah it's
pretty big big yeah yeah
so this i think it's like a couple
hundred micrograms or milligrams it's
not very much right um you take one
gummy each day
um
to be honest like i'm not real the
reason why i'm not taking like vitamin d
or multivitamin in a gummy format is i'm
not really doing it for that reason but
it's the
key habit reward loop right like if i if
i get to have something that tastes nice
at the end that might help i've been
really consistent with my habits
okay so you're taking your you're taking
all of your supplements which will
probably be some creatine tablets and
vitamin d and a blah blah blah and then
once you've done all of that you get to
have a nice apple cider vinegar
sweetie
exactly i'm down for that i don't i
don't totally hate i feel like you two
haven't haven't taken that very very
well but to be honest
i'm really proud of it and it's really
helped me
so hopefully it'll help one other person
yeah the meta habit if you know if it's
creating or something that's going to do
something then it's a useful
thing to have that you you stick to
doing every day my
what i'm going to go away and do after
this episode
is look into is there a substantive
difference between
collagen and gelatin because i think
they're really really similar if not the
same
and obviously a bag of haribo
is
completely gelatin based
so
are they rebranding haribo as a health
supplement
so they it has um marine collagen
in the gummy fish there's an ingredient
yeah
okay
but
like i
just to be fully clear like i'm not i'm
not here saying like collagen
gummies are the way to take collagen i'm
not even sure if collagen's worth
bothering with it's something i wanted
to try because there's some research
around like joint pain when you train
i thought what what better way to do
that than have a nice sweetie at the end
of my supplement routine
yeah i don't i don't totally hate it
okay
tough crowd there so yeah okay it's just
youtube better be bringing some
fantastic comments yeah okay speaking of
which
what have you got
so you'll be pleased to know actually
i've rejigged looked through all my life
hacks i've done some analysis i've
ranked them
and created a more kind of sophisticated
classification system for them
um and so what i've arrived at is
basically
physical and digital life hacks
so
in terms of the digital ones
i've got a couple of iphone appy ones
now some of these probably will seem
obvious
but
it occurred to me that it won't become a
knowledge to everyone
if there's a website that you frequently
want to access that doesn't have its own
app
you can turn it into
effectively an app on your home screen
so go to the website press share
there'll be an option called
share to home screen or add to home
screen just to make a point there share
is the
upward arrow poking out at the bottom of
a uh rectangle at the bottom of the
screen right
that's the one yep so um share to home
screen you can add it onto your
thing and then you can select the icon
so we recommend because we're snidey and
our we don't have our own iphone app but
we do have a web app and a web portal
that is iphone optimized so
if you're a member of the propane
protocol you can just save it as an app
on your phone and
most people don't know the difference
share and add to home screen
i do that quite a bit actually what have
you got what websites are you using that
for
mainly like courses were part of so
things that i go to like the login page
a lot
um
so specific websites that you would like
would find yourself like going to
regularly it's just a it's a button
press and it's open and you're off you
often stay logged in as well which is
quite cool
so like if you're doing a
any kind of course or i suppose i can't
think of any other examples there are
some apps that work as
um like work as a web app
so like some diet trackers and things
like that will work as natively that's
how they work they don't have an ios app
um
yeah that's
really good really good suggestion you
said thank you for bringing that i'm not
going to make fun of it or anything i
think it was a
really well thought out we've all used
it how can we how can we take the piss
out of it right
get out of the way my turn please
uh going
all the way back to life hacks 101 you
will remember that we spoke about
optimize dot me with brian johnson
uh what you may not be aware of now is
that brian has made the entire
optimized.me library with over a
thousand plus ones and 600 book
summaries available for free so if you
go to
optimize that's o p t i m i z e
dot me
uh you can sign up for free and
say what you want about brian's demeanor
right which we've all taken the piss out
of quite a lot
he
put a ridiculous amount of work into
that every book that he goes through has
got a worksheet that you can use it's
got notes it's got an audio transcript
it's got summaries
it's got um affirmations that you can go
through and then he did those 101 master
classes where he took the best ideas
from the best books within one subject
area so sleep or mental resilience
or habits or whatever and he would take
10 different books the best ideas from
each of those and put them into one one
hour long
super lecture again with worksheets and
everything else and now it's available
for free now the reason it's available
for free is because he is trying to do
a cohort based coaching thing called
heroic.us
and this is the freemium front end of
the funnel to get people on the mailing
list
but as lead magnets go
this is about as high quality
lead magnet as i think you can get
you've got an awesome partner app for
ios
and
if you want to get a good book summary
thing and also the master classes i
highly recommend just going and checking
it out is it's for free
really really good i'd go as far as to
say it's formidable it's a real mature
product and it's a mother of a lead
magnet man oh you'd be annoyed if you
were the person who's subscribed monthly
for the last eight years and then he
goes oh it's free now
well to be honest i'm a bit annoyed are
neither of you a bit annoyed did you
probably never paid i didn't yeah
oh there we are
story of my life
i think i played for a couple of months
of it
interesting
so
you know the liver king is also called
brian johnson
and the lead singer of ac dc
imagine if they made a super group
well they might be the same person hey
guys brian here fairly impressive aren't
they for various reasons very different
reasons but they're all in the public
eye yep
brian johnson from optimize looks
incredibly lean in
the video i keep seeing of him promoting
this heroic.us thing looks like a test
tube baby it's it's lane bordering on
perhaps unwell
isn't it
well he looks like a long distance
runner yeah he does he does which is he
looks like someone who's doing a lot of
cardio all of whom look unwell
you know most triathletes
are pretty lean people
you think god glad i don't do that so
are you two gonna
are you gonna get back into optimize now
it's free
i've got the answer i've not opened it
in a while it's
this comes down to i think we discussed
this on a recent life hacks of book
summary services
in general things like blinkist are kind
of good adverts for the book but they're
never really a substitute for the full
thing i think the best solution that i
found or the best reason to use a book
summary is that it's the prospecting
scouting mode do i want to give this
book that a bunch of people have told me
to read a shot oh well i'll dedicate 20
minutes to seeing the summary and if
that speaks to me then i'll go out and
commit time to reading the full thing
which is
you know from a time-saving perspective
pretty good investment a lot of value in
that yeah because
if if you just sit and read it it would
be three four hours into it before you
can really make a decision as to like
should i continue with this or not
actually there's two
two more elements of why i think that
might be a good idea one is to remember
points from books that you've already
read and might have forgotten
and another one is to
perhaps see if there's some takeaways
that you missed
from a book that you've read as well so
you actually
there is quite a bit of it but not for
probably the reason that people think
the reason people think is oh i don't
need to read the book at all and i can
just go through this summary and
whatever it's like no you're not gonna
yeah that's a bit of an insult to the
author as well like i spent all this
time writing
the stories and anecdotes and books to
stuff to fill the book and then you've
just said oh it's not important i don't
need those 80 000 words i've got this
baldy guy here this baldy distance
runner and he's
he's gonna do it right johnny what you
got
i'm concerned that we've said this one
before it's very similar to what we've
literally just been speaking about but
it's something that i
didn't use properly until this
experience this
water down 75 hard so one of the things
was reading daily you both know how i
feel about reading
i'm still on the fence about it to be
honest about
whether i've i've read enough at this
point and it's what i'm still in the
action phase but i used um
i'm just waiting for useless reaction
read wise
the oh
i use the read wise app synced with my
kindle and then say it automatically
syncs and saves all the highlights to
read wise and then gives you like the
the scrolling you you both might see me
share the stuff to instagram
occasionally ones that i find very
useful
i think you do this already chris you
might already both do this i probably
even got it from a previous life hack
but that's the ultimate test right when
a life hack comes around again
so is that is that something you've both
done
i pay for read-wise yeah it's
it's great like it fully they they are
such an impressive company i'm part of
their
uh developer discord
and
they
they're just they integrate with all of
the external brain type apps so
you can send things to your notion your
obsidian evernote whatever
and they're developing something which i
don't know if i'm allowed to talk about
i'm part of the beta
group but they they're developing a
reader app
and i think that's all i can say
okay so do you use
you use the like the publicly available
read wise for just note taking reviewing
notes you've been made previously from
the books
to be honest i the reason i pay is for
the reader app rather than read wise
main function
so i i use it just because when i
highlight stuff on kindle big kindle
reader i now have whatever
a few thousand
highlights of quotes from books and then
every morning at
seven a.m i receive four of them in my
email inbox and then if i want to go
back and get them uh also if you've done
it with books which aren't on the amazon
cloud i ones that you haven't purchased
but documents that you've sent to
yourself which i do a lot with send to
kindle you then need to plug it in but
once you plug it in it will check
which ones are already in the archive it
won't re-add them twice it'll check
those across it'll add them in um yeah
it's it's an unbelievably
simple and impressive way to do things
and it's really good easy free content
as well so every day you've got a bunch
of quotes that you can just throw up on
your instagram or create into a story or
that just you can post on twitter
do you think it does as well
apple books yeah and soon thanks for
loads of stuff articles like twitter
bookmarks email lists like just
everything so because you see if you
like sending stuff to read wise don't
they on on twitter like in the
in the comments of a thread save threads
or read wise or whatever yeah
because the the feature that i didn't
know they did because i i started doing
it i was like oh i'm building up this
like library of like interesting points
from books that i realistically i would
never never go back to that book and
like refine that quote again and then i
realized you can just go through books
you've read previously
this might be what you meant chris you
can go through books you've read
previously that you weren't using read
wise at the time but you've already read
and it takes all the popular highlights
from that book and sends them to you
no i wasn't aware of that no i didn't
know that yeah so it's like for example
like um
atomic habits like i've obviously read
before it just takes all the popular
stuff like all the popular quotes from
that or the most highlighted sections
that sends that to read-wise as well so
you can just build i think it solves
like the
for me anyway it's sort of like the
frustrating thing about reading that it
feels like you read a book and then it's
just like
vanishes so at least at least you remind
yourself of the stuff you've read one of
the problems that you have with reading
on kindle is that you don't have as many
ways to export stuff from that that
you've been learning into other programs
and i'm very
increasingly i'm just letting the good
[ __ ] stick but
just
going through something highlighting it
and doing that is sweet however you can
also do a note so this is available on
paper white it's also available on um
the oasis so you highlight something
which is what it does that would add it
to your highlights that would also
appear on read wise but then you can
press note which opens up a text box
where you can add just if you've got a
thought about this this links with this
idea maybe this is a question that i
want to have or whatever a lot of the
time people write this in the margins of
books
that also appears
on read-wise so not only does the
highlight but also the prompt that you
gave yourself about something else about
why it's interesting yeah yeah exactly
it's pretty
impressive i'm read-wise i'm down people
should go check it out there might be a
free trial um it'll be linked in the
comments below anyway uh yousef what you
got
so this is on the same vein
this is for so what we've just talked
about but for physical books
so
i've got a pile of physical books that
people have got me as gifts or i've just
picked up and you're like i really want
to read it but i just can't
find the justify the time to read it and
then
go back highlight it pull out the stuff
that's relevant to me put it into my
notes
and so a way to solve that
is an app called otter
as in the animal
and what you can do is it you can just
set it recording with this green off
on the side of your desk or something
and as you're reading
as you're highlighting you can just
speak aloud
highlights or bits that you find useful
and you can leave it running in the
background and it'll transcribe
660 minutes per month so you get quite a
big allowance for that
so
what it does is as you read through
you'll just say occasional things
allowed or sentences that you find
useful
you basically don't feel like you're
taking highlights because you're just
speaking as you're reading
and then it transcribes it turns into a
document that's time stamped and then
you can export that to whatever system
you use
well we do know that this is what amazon
alexa and google home hub and the like
apple airplay that's what they're doing
all the time in any case so what they've
done is they've just given you your own
personalized version of what
of what everyone's smart speaker is
doing to them all just made it useful
for you rather than just for them yes
crazy
would you use that johnny would you
would you just decide to record a
conversation between you becca and
dexter
just
trying to discipline the dog around the
house
i don't really read i'd love to read
physical books there's something nice
about them but like
there's the ones behind me on the
bookshelf and that's it like i don't i
would never buy a physical book but yeah
if i suppose if i had a ton of them
um
yeah it sounds a good idea what's the
website yousef
the web the app is called otter
is it no so there's no desktop version
right there is a desktop version as well
yeah so it's a web app and you can use
the m1 um
like
sneaky port thing as well
what's that once again once you keep so
you can install ipad and iphone apps on
your m1 mac
but it's they don't always work that
smoothly oh okay interesting does it
open up like a iphone screen or an ipad
screen on your phone yeah on your laptop
sorry right
okay right so i've got
this is one that i took from shane
parish which i think you will probably
both agree with but i doubt actually
adhere to
um
shane parish made a point that you
should always pay invoices early because
the people who pay the invoices early
will get preferential treatment in
future so as soon as you receive an
invoice through from someone that is
expecting payment just pay it as you
receive it or as soon as possible and
then send them an email all right mate
all done when it comes to you needing
something from that person
uh you've got a project that's on a
tight timeline you need them to go above
and beyond whatever it is
that person is going to be prepared to
take it to the next level for you
because they know that they're going to
get paid
too sweet as opposed to the person
that's taken the entire whatever net 30
from the end of the month
like
piss
yeah there's no advantage to doing that
like yeah okay you get the cash flow but
if you're ever going to be doing
business with that person again you're
playing repeated games with them like
it makes sense to build a good
relationship
it's such a [ __ ] good hack however
didn't you get popped from the hmrc for
submitting your tax payment late last
year
yousef
so
yes
that's because our trusted accountant
was like
oh [ __ ] no that you are right sorry i've
i've accused you of something that our
accountant did to everybody
i think it's actually um hmrc's fault in
this case okay
they they had me down as a fake doctor
when you're a real one
i don't know if i count as one now
we're a doctor i think you do don't you
you still got the still got the letters
in front of your name and after your
name
true i'm just not like if someone
shouted on a plane is there a doctor on
board would you go
yeah it's a very long story how long
have you gotten yeah
so
my accountant was like whoa well mate
like there's someone having a heart
attack technically i'm i'm doing kind of
marketing strategy
at the moment right so what would you
like your funnel optimizing right now i
know i know i know i know he's dying
he's dying he's time but let's talk
about your cpm and your click-through
rate because he flows terrible at the
minute yeah that's the biggest that's
the real emergency always pay invoices
early if you do people are gonna treat
you better super super simple heuristic
everybody should adhere to it
businesses often tend to like manage
their working capital by paying things
as late as they can
like big big businesses with huge
invoices but i definitely agree on a
personal level
like if something because especially it
just creates like mental drag as well
doesn't it like it sits in your inbox or
it sits in it like however you receive
it and you're like i don't need to do
that and there's like so much resistance
around paying it when really it takes
you two minutes yeah if you just do it
it goes away the dude that's come around
to fix the boiler or your roofing
displays and stuff yeah get it get it
yeah um
i heard uh
sorry just off the back of that
especially interested to hear what you
think about this chris with because i
think it's a very us thing
um a tip was the first time you go into
a bar or restaurant if you're going to
be innocent in a new location for a long
period of time
is aggressively tip
the person who helps you so like the
person who serves you
or the waiter yeah like force it but the
example was was tip tip 100
um the first time because like every
subsequent time you deal with that
person you'll get like preferential
tables they'll serve you first
what do you think about that as a as a
concept
in principle sounds great but in
practice i think there's the turnover of
staff
is going to be so high you know it's
that one person that's going to do it
plus maybe what the three or four people
that they speak to about that [ __ ]
that gave them 100 bucks
so
i just don't think i don't think that
it's going to pay out and man they are
used to tipping so much out here
some of the presets when you go on uh
see they have an ipad right where they
do their stuff on their side and then
they turn it over and you you have to
select how much you want to tip
afterward 18 20 and 25 it's some percent
it's got sometimes on that so if it's a
a good sized meal you're talking about a
fair whack of a tip and as there's no
option for zero is there well there is
but you would have to edit there is
custom and then if you did
you're in you're insane and then they
take it back right so you have to flip
it back over and it tells them what
you've done so it's like showing showing
your homework to the teacher to get
shamed into like i put zero it's
showing your homework that says i've not
done the homework
it's as an englishman who obviously i'm
genetically averse to tipping
it's maybe
something that would work better in the
uk then because people are so averse to
it
so the reason i wanted chris's opinion
was i just i think he's he's had the
behind-the-scenes knowledge of like that
sort of service-based industry like does
that do people respond well to stuff
like that i feel like the answer is no
they used to
seen big tips man i think a fair bit at
the time um
yeah of a like flex isn't it you know
who can give the biggest tip and that
sort of stuff so i don't believe that
i'll buy that i'll buy the biggest steak
but not nice give away the biggest tip
what you got
um
so this is in relation to
like anything that you buy
like regularly so
um
supplements is the easiest example so
like whenever something whenever you go
down from having two of something to one
of something
that's when you then order stuff like
order the new new round of it so like
one of these zero examples
yeah exactly that's a much better way of
explaining it thank you um
so i've had examples where like i'll be
on my last version of something my last
thing of something and then you're like
i'll i'll order it later or later and
you inevitably end up
three four days a week without that
thing
so really simple rule you can apply it
to like whatever you buy on a recurring
basis or
you fall for what jeff bezos wants
everybody to do which is this like
subscribe and save option on amazon
where it just comes monthly anyway
i've not have you got any subscribe and
saves i don't have a single one
what level of accuracy do you need it
has to be something like contact lenses
where you need you know you will put it
you need you wake up and you're like i
know that i will need eyesight today
so i will definitely use my contact
lenses but if it's even toothpaste
the variants can end up with like a
massive backlog after a year you have a
month where your grip strength increased
a little bit and you've just been
pumping through it yeah i am so having a
buffer level of products that you use is
a really smart idea
uh or
who would be another one would be to
have
a uh always in one cupboard
um like buffer level that you touch so
you go into that one whenever you you're
running out of the other stuff and then
you work on top of it so rather than
swapping between the two you've just got
one that's always the buffer level you
must do that
oh yes that's true you need to have a
toilet roll but then there's a bunch of
downstream kitchen roll is a valid
alternative tissues are a valid
alternative and then if that doesn't
work sucks so you know there are there
is a hierarchy here of
that's a real emergency like running on
fumes isn't it yeah that's second year
second year university living in the
first house that you've ever lived in
[ __ ] mate mate have you used all the
toilet rolls i've used all the socks
mate
[Laughter]
right yes
that's it have a buffer level and order
in it well one is a new zero
nice that's good
um so this is a digital one also iphone
like
you guys might just be like oh yeah
obviously but moving between apps with
any iphone that's above a
nine or a ten
so if you don't have the button
rather than like
swiping up because i've seen so many
people do this where they they swipe up
and then like find the new app on the
home screen and then press it again
you're like you can just move between
them by
putting your thumb on the little white
bar and moving left and right
so that one it's almost that that one's
so obvious that you forget about it that
one i've used a lot something that i
used to do with a button that i haven't
brought back across onto the new
buttonless iphones you remember when you
used to double tap and then be able to
move between them
oh yeah you would be able to see them
all now you can do that if you go from
the bottom slowly
and it'll open out into all of the
windows that's just a function that i've
never been able to
whatever instantiate into my my brain's
movement do you miss the button
not really
it's not like what you were referring to
yourself that what you what chris has
just described so i'll like push it push
it up a little bit and then swipe across
to go between apps
so you can just you can do it without
pushing up and then it just goes
straight to the next app or what chris
is describing is it like puts them all
into a floating panel and then you can
you can choose
um
yeah yeah so if you go back down to one
of the apps and then if you just go
across the very bottom of the screen and
you swipe your thumb from left to right
my god i i didn't know that oh so that's
the one indicated
so
he was me saying like oh this is so
obvious that i i i thought you meant the
like the push it up bump it into like a
carousel and then go between no no
this is the mother because you're
usually going between two
apps right it's rare that you're going
between it's rarer that you're going
between three it's like oh here's a
here's an address copying it from my
calendar yeah doing whatever the [ __ ]
into uber or something
i think it's better about the new like
the new iphone set up where it's all in
the the app
um
directory whatever they call it where i
just search now i just like drag down
and search the name of the app rather
than like having to deal with the home
screen i think that's a way
like
it's better for like a screen time
perspective so you don't get caught in
the loop of
email instagram facebook whatever i'm
going in choosing exactly what i want
yeah this is what i came here to do it's
the alfred of the iphone
yeah it is uh right okay this is one
that i've been doing for the last few
years so i've been traveling a lot up
until kobit and then after covert as
well i guess i've been traveling a fair
bit as well and i did it uh on the first
road trip i did around america a few
years ago and then have just done it
ever since i've bought a particular
fragrance for each trip
so i've done a little bit of research i
have a bunch of friends that are
fairly knowledgeable in aftershaves and
i'll ask them look man this is what i'm
doing this is where i'm going what do
you think
and i'll then go into fenix or somewhere
into a department store try them and
then pick one and that'll be the
aftershave that i have for the trip and
then usually whatever the six months
twelve months or something after the
trip obviously but what it means is that
whenever i put that fragrance back on
i've got all of these memories attached
to that smell and it reminds me of that
fourth of july in nashville or that trip
to austin or whatever it is
and it's just great and now i've got
little bits left of each one of them and
if i ever want to remind myself about
that trip i can just wear that and it
gives me nice that is really nice
that is lovely it's crazy how much
like a memory is attached to smell like
when you put an aftershave on and it
like takes you back like five ten years
have you ever met a girl who
wears the same perfume as like one of
your accents yes and it's it's just
instantly strange
so in my like in my induction in
accountancy in like the first week they
you the given like a presentation about
like
what tie to wear to match the shape of
your face and all that sort of stuff and
one of the things they said was like we
recommend not wearing any perfume
aftershave in case it creates like the
wrong environment between you and a
client and you can't like undo it like
once once you've gone in and you like
smell of the smell of their partner or
smell of their partner that's it like
that they'll they'll associate you with
the deal
you can't unpick that so it's very
powerful
that's yeah yeah what's the what was it
the number one
aftershave that you've bought like
what's the if you've got friends who
have knowledge with their stuff like
what's
what's your number one ranked aftershave
uh so maizon kurdijan uh bakarat roos
540 it is
it is uh it's an apps just put bakarat
rouge 540 in on uh google and it'll come
up it is without a doubt one of the best
smelling things that i've ever
uh i've ever smelled in my entire life
it's unbelievable wow uh it's so unisex
technically um although it would be
fairly strong i think if you're a girl
to wear it but
it's just outstanding like it just it's
pure happiness and it lasts for
eight hours um so the guy who is the
um
whatever is perfumer for um a bunch of
big current
fragrance houses
he does the stuff for them so he'll go
and do whatever home sport and what was
that blue one that had the the sailors
uh torso jeans oh
with with the stripes um it wasn't
versace was it that was a 90s that cost
no no it wasn't
anyway that one that every guy had for a
short amount of time he was the guy that
designed that he's designed some of the
biggest fragrances and uh maizon
kurdijan is his private perfume house
where he just does stuff for himself so
this is kind of like i know pretty legit
then yeah a producer for all of the big
r b artists then deciding that he's
going to start making his own stuff
and it's it's pretty expensive i think a
bottle is maybe about a normal 70 ml
bottles maybe 250 300 pounds but you
don't need that much of it it'll last
you a year and it smells
that i you can't really put a price on
like feeling nice
how many squirts do you use uh usually
four
so like four squirts wow two two one
wrist wrist wrist neck neck done yeah
nice
i bet yourself i imagine you make sure
it doesn't touch your skin because of
estrogen so since i spoke to anthony j
he advised doing that yeah i used to
always think about ray on the neck
um but now i just use a dab of essential
oil which mike finds hilarious like i
was on the way essential oil sandalwood
just on the top of my head and he was
like did you just put a drop of oil on
your head i'm like yeah
so you're walking around honking of
sandalwood or lavender or something yeah
just some kind of herb
very herby but that's your musk isn't it
as as somebody from egypt that's the
smell of my people
to be honest arabs
for all of their faults smell lovely
you're right
it's very good smell habibi oh don't
worry habibi it's not for you yeah
jean-paul gaultier that was it [ __ ]
john paul gautier thank you feels good
that doesn't it to get it get it out of
the system uh do you know what the what
i think the hormone is or the
neurotransmitter that's released when
you connect something that's like that
where you solve a problem
vasopressin
could i be right so you said probably
yes it's
associated with memory and short-term
memory so it's probably like the reward
for
connected yeah
mission complete bit of a suppressant
get in so tim ferriss used to get
intranasal vasopressin spray to learn
japanese vocabulary
it's a very conference thing to do
because it gives you a short term
uh improvement in your memory
oh [ __ ]
taking a big line of memory probably
feels quite nice
like a little bit of like get in in the
morning
remembering everything right johnny what
you got
uh mine is a
mac app that is connected to a concept
that is also linked to tim ferriss
called morning pages
we heard of that before
uh is that the artist's way thing from
junior yeah exactly yeah so it's a form
of journaling the idea being like you
well the the artist's way concept is you
write for three pages a day of just
unfiltered like whatever you're thinking
and it's supposed to be like a form of
therapy basically you know you like get
all of your thoughts out and it just is
a way of sort of processing
things that you that you're like dealing
with or trying to think about that you
wouldn't necessarily have that
conversation out loud as it were but
writing it out can help process that
morning pages is a
because my handwriting looks like an
eight-year-old's morning page is a way
of doing it digitally and it's an app
that is designed that gives you
um a daily word
uh target and it analyzes the
tone of the writing to whether it has a
negative or or a positive
um like frame to it and then it also
pulls out themes that keep occurring in
the
um in the
christ
excited about that part it's really cool
this is so sophisticated yeah so it you
can see like january had like a negative
like it's a red bar below a line
february had a positive tone and like
these were the things you were talking
about on days you were
they had a negative tone these are
things you talking about days yet
there's so much that can be done with
that because if if when you log in it
says like what's your mood out of 10 or
how did you sleep or something like that
and it starts drawing across
correlations and associating it with
different themes then it starts to get
really exciting
it's more just it's weird how like um
the strangest thing is how
uh you look back on an entry and you're
like god like
i have no emotional reaction to that
whatsoever anymore but at the time it
was like really a really heightened
emotional thing and also how consistent
like certain things that annoy you
crop up
that you that like i certainly wasn't
aware of like you think oh this thing's
happened today and that's a frustrating
thing but actually it happened in
january as well
so do you think it's like this one-off
event have you ever looked back on
notes from say two years ago and you see
something that annoyed you at the time
and you think oh that just doesn't
bother me anymore that's always a nice a
nice win it's a sign of progress isn't
it i think i've always said it would be
great if you could take a
screenshot of your memory
so if you could go back you know how
time machine on your macbook works and
you can go back and restore your machine
to an older version if you could just
visit an older version of your
the texture of your mind right and if
you to go back to it
three years ago and think about the
neuroses and the anxieties and the
concerns and the worries and the things
that consumed you
almost all of them would probably not
even feature in your mind now your
problems are more sophisticated bigger
that's true more so frustrating though
wouldn't it because you'd be shouting at
it being like stop doing that or stop
worrying about this and you couldn't
communicate with them yeah
yeah i think that's the
so
this uh one of the other things is
journaling right so like i've tried that
was one of the things i had to do daily
and i've tried like the six minute diary
the five minute journal like lots of
other ways of journaling and i don't i i
think the only way that i've tried that
i felt like a
even like an immediate benefit from so
like as soon as i finished i was like oh
like that feels better to like get that
out of my head was was this this way of
doing it and there's no like structure
to it so i feel it can feel a bit
pointless sometimes if you're like i
just need to get on with my day but it's
the value of looking back at previous
entries and being like wow like
that problem
is firstly i handled it really well i
was worried about it i handled it really
well or it's not really a thing anymore
um and you can pick out stuff that makes
you happy as well that you don't realize
like things that happen in a day that
and obviously add those back in
normal yeah it's cool what
what's the website is there a desktop
version yeah it's a desktop it's a
desktop app called morning pages okay
i should say as well
that if this is past the johnny test who
is definitely the the most skeptical of
journaling among the three of us
then it's got to be good it's a high
watermark yeah for you to do that and
then how much do you have to write
you can set that
how much do you choose to write
i have it on 250 words i believe a day
yeah because i think the original
artist's way by julia cameron is three
full pages written it is yeah which is
that was that's one of the main reasons
that i've never done it because i'm just
thinking oh that's such a
huge barrier to get over
yeah so exactly so that would
that would take me
uh well i don't i've never actually
tried
a while yeah
and i think like with this stuff it is
all about like keeping the resistance
low
and doing it consistently so
like you i had the thought of like it'd
be cool to try i've heard quite a few
people who i like look up to you talk
about it
but this idea of like sitting down with
a little book each morning and writing
like my handwriting's so bad that i i
want to be able to look back on it and
read it firstly
and it's illegible even to you yeah so i
guess it's scrawled two days later so
what's the point right so
over the last couple of years in
hospital quite a lot of stuff is still
physically written so we're not fully
digital
and
you get so frustrated at writing because
when you're used to typing really fast
and then you're like oh my god i have to
like
scroll this out and it
it's annoying because of the friction to
you're so used to being able to smooth
flow from brain to output
yeah you surf what you got
physical one
i posted this on twitter yesterday and
people went nuts over it like people
missing the point and getting annoyed at
it but what i said was
potatoes for cutting rice for bulking
and if everyone just followed that rule
would all be fine
and
people in the comments being like oh
well but it all turns to starch and
sugar anyway so we're all like well i
could eat loads of mcdonald's fries and
you're like well yeah obviously but
that's not the point is it like the
point is
try and overeat boiled potato
and get back to me but that sounds like
a [ __ ] meal so what else can you do with
potato
the i think when you're dieting you want
to make food as boring as possible like
i think what a lot of people and it's a
big mistake that a lot of the kind of
eating disorder
fueled instagram
influencers do is they they really
pedestalize and worship food and make it
super
like it's almost like they're just blue
balling themselves with food when
really
you shouldn't you should be making it as
unpalatable and boring as possible and
as filling as possible
you could mix it with the uh
chicken in a tin chris
with chicken with white rice chunky
chicken yeah you know white chicken
yeah so your argument here is that
potatoes are less dense
in terms of their
the less calorie dense so on the satiety
index somebody did a study where they
they ranked
foods from
um
all different types of foods and and
related it to 100 calories of sliced
white bread
and so it gives it an index of what was
the how many calories did someone eat
subsequent to eating 100 calories of ex
food
and potato boiled potato was the highest
one so it was
people ate the least after eating
potato
and i think the lowest one was like
crisps or croissant like something like
really
almost like
wafer air but really high calorie
density garlic bread
i i would say basil for butter if you
were to give me the difference between
like a super low-fat spread of some kind
on a nice baked potato a nice jacket
right that's been cross-cut and been put
in and it's it's just a tiny little bit
overdone not much but a tiny little bit
overdone just so this is dude
that versus a boiled potato and it's the
same it's still a potato low-fat
some something
i'm fine with that like
it's it's when people say oh what about
mcdonald's fries like well that's not
really potato that that's just like palm
oil or whatever
used with potato as a vessel for it
with quite questionable amounts of
potato as well it might not even be
potato it might be some kind of plastic
polymer that they've melted down and
pushed through it's just estrogen isn't
it everything is pure it just identifies
as potato no one can question that these
days so it used to be used to be a
potato that now identifies as some
estrogen and you heard about 100 beef
what's that just before we move on hold
on
i my issue was with the rice piece of
this
just because i feel like the the beef
will move us off the subject and i want
to get to the bottom of it
potato for cutting i agree
but rice for bulking
rice it's just the bodybuilder staple
isn't it but i i find rice really
filling is it like you put a small
serving of rice in a pan and cook it
expands it's a huge meal really for the
calories don't you think like why not
like
butter potatoes we should do a challenge
for youtube like will it depends like
what's a better base
buttery biscuit base what's a better
base for carbohydrates
for you to add into a meal
unless you're going to go pasta which is
then you're playing are you [ __ ]
about with gluten
what
what what do you
what beats rice
this is johnny's an absolute sandwich
boy so like oh he just wants everything
to be a marx and spencer's
to be honest taste of the world
[ __ ] whatever it is all day breakfast
or something i suppose if i was managing
johnny's bulk i would i would have to
say like you know what just go to town
on sandwiches because
you wouldn't even need to tell me well
you're in the element there aren't you
so yeah chris is this native environment
it doesn't matter where we're going who
we're going to see what we're going to
do i'm most excited about the mns simply
food on the way the opportunity to do
sandwiches on our way on our way to see
bring me the horizon guest list
play
a huge arena
what are you most excited for tonight
johnny oh well i do think that m s have
just released their new simply food
range which has actually got like a
prawn something something like let me
check if whether what time weather be
closes chris because that's going to
determine what time we set off
the meal deal might have finished by
then what's the beef what happened with
beef
oh so there was some kind of scandal
where
mcdonald's were saying on on on like
wall placards 100 beef
in their burgers
and what had happened was they acquired
a subsidiary company
that was called 100 beef limited oh my
god
and they got into some kind of lawsuit
and
had to change the thing because it was
obviously a false claim but they would
they they were misleading yeah it's
technically correct because
because burgers have like carbs in them
don't they they have like filler
ingredient that actually makes the carb
count like i remember back in the keto
days having a burger and looking like
that that's it 30 grams of carbs and all
these burgers from a special place
didn't you too yeah not anyone's
thoughts has anyone thought about
starting up a uh sports massage therapy
business called not a rapist
i mean
i don't think you'd get any customers if
you called it that but well why
that's it surely you have to get more
customers than a rapist next door
but it's not between like that's not the
two options
yeah there are other people in the
market that's the trouble well that's
what you think that's what you say they
want you to believe yeah what would you
choose if there was two doors
between a rapist and not a rape
[Music]
that's like it's one of those mind games
isn't it where like you can only ask one
one question there's two people standing
in front of two doors
one always lies one always rapes yeah
right okay moving on um so i got i got a
bit of i got a bit of pushback on my
newsletter this week for putting this in
uh but i don't care uh 12 foot dot ios
that's number one number two ft dot io
so this person that has made this
website realized that in order for
websites to be optimized for google
ad
keyword search they have to actually
make a completely unpaywalled version of
every article that's paywalled so that
google can search it
without the paywall and he has made this
website 12 foot dot io
saying show me a 10 foot paywall and
i'll give you a 12 foot ladder and this
unlocks
any
pretty much any so the observer the
spectator the guardian
new york times washington post
uh and you can just append to the
beginning
https colon backslash backslash 12 foot
dot
website
i think it explains it on the on the
website anyway how to do it plus there's
an ios and an android app that's
partnered up with it and it's completely
free journalists hate him is it all is
it also not completely illegal
well what would be illegal about it
that's that um google uh
keyword search is available for google
to access and pretty sure they're just
finding
a version that exists on the internet
like it's not bypassing the pay wall
precisely yeah right this is just a
different way to view it now don't get
me wrong uh i think that journalists the
ones that are good people like douglas
murray should be paid for their work uh
however
if you don't like a journal if you want
to hate read them
this is
a good way to do it someone complained
about the fact that um it didn't work on
my website like i don't have any paywall
content on my website so there's nothing
nothing there's no secret yeah yeah uh
that being said please do support
whatever publications you actually care
about and use this for the ones that you
hate read
interestingly the thing that stops me
from signing you know someone sends you
a financial times article or something
from the independent or whatever and you
want to read it the thing that stops
like if it just had apple pay and it was
50p or whatever a hundred percent what's
wrong for a one-off um payments in the
article yeah that would be a really
really smart thing to do
like it's not the it's not the money
that's the problem for me it's the ball
lake of like you have to type in your
email address and then check the thing
and
yeah yeah
apple pay would fix everything johnny
uh
this one is
another app
um i might have spoken to you about this
before chris but
you might so
chris years ago referred me onto a
meditation coach called brian
who introduced me to shinzon young
and there's a huge pdf then like he has
a book and his methods decently
complicated i think that's fair to say
like it's not just sit and pay attention
to your nose and um
and focus on your breath and it's not
like head space
um there's a lot to it and i've i've
often struggled to like piece it all
together to understand it there is
actually
an app
for all of this now don't know whether
you've come across this before chris no
so shinzen young's method
is basically
broken down into a course
on an app that is progressive and
systematic and takes you through all of
the methods
with guidance
you can take it's everything from like a
five minute meditation through to an
hour meditation the app is called bright
mind
and it is
[Music]
i believe it was originally shin zone
who was doing the
like the the guided meditations it's now
somebody else is he still alive
as far as i know
yeah as far as getting on isn't he so
does bright mind follow the five ways
framework
oh what would the concentration clarity
equanimity
oh that is
very good but the thing i like the most
about it which is a weird like obviously
so i've completed the course it's really
really helpful um but you know when
someone says like i quite want to get
into meditation like what what what
would you recommend
and you're like
well
probably not headspace probably not calm
like maybe here's a youtube video like
to just be able to say
that's an entire like a to z course that
explains the entire thing from the very
basics through to the really advanced
take from it what you want how long did
it take you to complete the full course
it's
chunky
that's not enough it's i don't even know
the answer that's the trouble
they'll be six months uh they'll
probably be like
it's probably one to two months of like
one meditation a day yeah and then
they're always adding stuff but like to
learn the method the five ways method
um it's at least daily are there
lectures to teach you the theory outside
of the right
yeah and then the separate like and it
like tracks all your meditation as well
so like it keeps your streaks and your
time and all sort of stuff but we mean
sorry i think everybody that's that's
read that five ways to know yourself if
you're interested in this if you just
google
five ways to know yourself shinzen young
um there's a pdf which is available for
free it'll be the top uh result on
google
and just have a read of that and that is
the most comprehensive breakdown of
is it my it's mindfulness meditation
right yusuf
yeah
yeah it's the most easy to understand
breakdown
three different modes three different
senses and a matrix basically that runs
over the top it's super easy very good
because it's systematic it's like for an
engineer's mind it's it's not there's no
woo
it's non-denominational it's just here's
what to do go and explore it
there's the
the
that stuff's like the labeling the
noting is actually part of an even
bigger system
that includes other forms of meditation
and the final lecture is like how to
design your own like training plan for
the week so like how to take all the
methods i've spoken about like mondays
you might do this tuesdays you might do
this and this if you want to get a coach
this is why you should get a coach and
this is the benefits you should look for
and if you want to go on retreats these
are some recommendations for retreats
like it it is the closest thing i've
come across to just like
here is how here's how to do meditating
now you now you know everything you need
to know how that's really really cool
what is your current meditation practice
having completed
that course
so i do
like a like push pull legs basically
so
uh like you'll be familiar with this
chris you know there's like focus in
focus out so i'll do one day of focus in
see here feel focus in yeah the next day
is see here feel focus out
and then the third day is
in and out see here feel and then back
to the beginning again sometimes on the
fourth day i'll do
focus on rest or focus on like he has
nurture positive and all these other
things as well auto focus
which is where you do nothing and let
sensations come and go yeah they do
nothing the
the whatever is
positive where you ding the bell and
think about it and then let it
reverberate that yeah all of that stuff
it's really cool and for the people that
are listening that are into their
meditation and are thinking that they
want to maybe try and give this a
a shot i would highly highly recommend
it i would also highly recommend maybe
thinking about getting a coach if you
enjoy that because it is it can get a
little bit complex without somebody to
explain it but yeah so i think if you if
you're like into training and you follow
a training plan or you're like that way
inclined
this i think will probably
sit well with you because it's
structured in a very similar way um and
the app will guide you through
the basics and if you listen to anything
i still really get it they recommend
coaches as well
so very nice
it's awesome nice
do you want physical or digital
physical
physical physical one please
learn to roll
so
this is just a
simple thing that i think a lot of
people
have never learned
and it's a great way to improve your
physical confidence to just
reduce the risk of injury it's so
versatile and
such an easy
entry grade skill to learn
i think if you have done gymnastics as a
child or if you're used to doing that
kind of stuff you would naturally like
roll out of a fall forward backwards
sideways
but being able to do it just means that
you're no longer afraid of just stacking
it and you you often will see people on
youtube on like fails compilations and
stuff and they are
what our friend david describes as
leptosomes like someone who is just
completely physically unintelligent and
just manages to like
make a big hens dinner of a simple fall
whereas if you know how to roll
you can avoid that it's the same
principle
as have you ever seen people who like
they're squatting a weight that they've
not they're not confident with the
weight and so they just cut the depth
because they know that if they fail it
they're not going to know how to dump
the bar
whereas if you go in you know how to
fail the squat properly you know how to
dump it and jump forward or put it on
the pins or whatever
then you can commit to full depth
because if you fail it's fine so it's
the same principle
i like it it's weird that we do that as
kids and the appropriation of playing
around on the ground and crawling about
and jumping and stuff like that is so
good and then you get to adulthood and
you're like oh no but emails i've got
them too
um and it just gets noble emails
aaron alexander my buddy that does the
align podcast he's got this thing where
um he says every adult should be able to
get up from the ground without using
their hands
uh he's got this
classic test
oh there was the challenge going around
recently where you put the
you're lying on your front and you've
got that's different
yeah that's hard that's yeah that's very
difficult what position are you in to
start off with that you have to get off
oh you could be on your back it could be
on your back so you could just sort of
roll your feet forward and then roll
yourself up and stand up which would be
pretty easy but generally you know that
requires a good bit of momentum you need
to be able to have some pretty good uh
mobility in your ankles if you were to
start on
your
front and weren't allowed to change from
your front
but still couldn't use your hands if you
don't have a broomstick pinning your
hands like your arms behind your back
that's a little bit easier um have you
seen that one what's that thing where
do people have to pick a
a cereal box up off the floor
or
something that's a party game that i i
always win
because you can do box
you can basically do the splits yeah you
can just take down yeah
cheating
what was i gonna say
the rolling
it's oh it was it was just like if you
ever watch a toddler do a back squat
like if you've ever watched a toddler
like go to pick something up they just
drop into like a yeah they just look
like a like a professional weightlifter
just drop into this like knees over
their toes
who's that
japanese
weightlifter not powerlifter
dude
like a 70 kilo
guy
dude i'm on about like a one he's like a
105
guy ridiculous squatter
um i'm pretty sure i showed you a video
yeah they've just been bred for it
haven't they like how
close to a billion people they just like
sift through them until they find
someone with the perfect female length
and they're like right so we're going in
the camp
okay
right so my one is
this was something that both aaron and
me uh came upon but i realized it while
i was spending a good bit of time in
airports towards the back end of last
year walk around the airport while
waiting for your flight so a lot of the
time you arrive at an airport early
you're going to be sat waiting for
departure to go i mean first off as a
hack you do not need to be at the gate
unless you are on uh first or business
class or some sort of preferential thing
at the front until they say last call
last call when you actually arrive is
just when they're starting to put
probably the normal groups in
and you're probably group five and group
three is about to go through now
obviously i'm not liable if you end up
getting stranded in some foreign country
but my point is
don't stand up when they say anybody
that's in that like you can start lining
up now
you don't need to do that also
just do laps at the airport airports are
pretty interesting places there's
interesting people and stuff happening
and
you can easily get i got my full days
ten thousand steps in
having a flight at seven a.m that i
arrived for at
5 30
and just did laps in the laps of austin
airport and then before i got on the
plane i was like
i've done my day's steps i'm gonna be in
the air for the rest of the day and i've
still done my day's steps it's it gives
you something to do as well because it's
sitting nervously like oh when when do i
get up and
like you just feel rubbish when you
on the plane whereas yeah if you've done
a load of steps you'd be like oh i've
actually done something useful
it's the it's when they say like
you know you can start leaving the
aircraft and everybody just goes mental
yeah that is my it's my least they stand
up like that yeah they don't even say
that it's as soon as you're here
boom
oh the seatbelt signs off yeah it's like
the starter pistol
it's like we're all gonna get off the
plane guys like you're not gonna be
trapped on the plane it'll all be all
right
just sit back down
but yeah have a walk around get some
steps in uh also obviously a lot of
places that you can do
couch stretch other bits and pieces to
try and loosen you off before you want
to get on if you want to do a little bit
of stretching or mobility
uh and hydrate as well
i think that that's the one of the main
impacts that you get from flying on a
plane
i also always have a bottle of water
with you so just buy a bottle of water
whatever before you leave and then just
when the lady comes around filling up
because she'll take a very large
two-liter bottle put that into a small
plastic cup and give you that and you'll
say actually would you just mind filling
up my bottle with your bottle
stay hydrated
decant
you can't
just don't buy the bottle before
security they can't allen you can't
no need to say that right johnny what
you got
uh
so
for any any long-term any long-time
listeners of modern wisdom they'll know
of life hacks specifically they'll know
that i've been on a mobility journey
so
loved romwad was told not to do wrong
mod got very upset tried doing wrong
what again
didn't really work injured my hamstring
have tried kelly sterett stuff on and
off didn't really like the app didn't
really have the interface i've tried
doing no mobility go wad as well you
tried go what yeah tried girl was but in
fact yeah god i tried that for ages
um
i think i've found
the app
and i've kind of meant i have mentioned
it before but this is the upgraded
version
and it is
does anyone do you want to guess
runward
no no
is there something we'll have heard of
knees over toes guy
i don't even know who that is oh ben
patrick is it the abs the kit lachlan
also no no it is it is kelly starrett's
new one okay
is this is this the ready state is this
his new one it is yeah so he brought out
a version of the ready state which felt
very much like a web app
that someone had saved to their desktop
um the latest one like you open the app
and it says to you um so firstly there's
a mobility test which is cool that
kelly's never done before so you
quantify your mobility it's a fairly
hard test to pass i scored pretty pretty
poorly on it
um um
there's just so much in there and it
filters it for you sir there's an
opening screen that says like what would
you like to do today so like do you want
to work on a specific body part you want
to prep for a movement or a sport do you
want to do the daily maintenance
um or do you want to do the mobility
test again filter that you can filter by
time filter by area filled by pain
filter by thing you're going to do that
fill up my thing you're going to recover
from so just open the app and just do
like a 10 minute thing like i'm
doing barbell relay i'll do i'll work on
my shoulder press press press and
they're all follow along as well they
didn't used to be follow along it used
to be kelly going
just get this and do this
couch stretch whereas now he like walks
through the entire thing so
as a as a like one-stop shop for i want
to improve my mobility
i've not found i'm sure someone will
tell me is a better thing but i've not
found anything better than that
it just it sounds like the workload of
making that app must be huge
so they modeled um mobility ward on
pornhub i think originally because like
who better to model like who else has
got lots of videos that need like
tagging and filtering and categorizing
it's like the original m1 website when
it first got launched was based on that
and they're just going to see
when you go stretching you can say like
brazilian bbw
yeah exactly
exactly that just to spice up ability i
have i have questions
questions can it be done at home
yes
how much equipment do you need
you can filter by equipment chris okay
so if you don't have a lacrosse ball or
a foam roller or
so like let's say you're traveling let's
say you're in a hotel you haven't got
anything
and you've only got 15 minutes
no problem you say
15 minutes no equipment
and like the specific body part you want
to work on and it'll it'll give you a
recommendation oh nice so it's kind of
like pressing the random button on
netflix a little bit because presumably
there's a bunch of different things that
it could come up with that it would give
you
yeah so it'll give you like a standard
it'll give you the daily maintenance as
a
as a default which is like the standard
programming that happens every day
but before you get to that you can say
well actually like my lower back hurts
today my lower back hurts i've got 20
minutes i've got a foam roller what can
i do and it gives you like three or four
videos to pick from
and then you just follow along and do
that and it gives you a streak a score
um
and you can
test to see whether it's working over
time by consistently doing the mobility
test are you more so
so i don't i really don't want to say
this because it's gonna jinx it i'm
gonna go deadlift after this and ping my
knee or something but this is the
longest period of time i have been
not injured for
i am uninjured
while training heavily we will
consistently pray to the injury gods
that that
continues i like it i like it that's
just the ready state
the ready state on the ios
app store i never know whether it's
available for android there is a web
website login version as well it's not a
web app it's a you can log into the same
back end very nice you've got the
comprehensive meditation and stretching
apps now with your journaling as well
this is one hell of a morning channeling
yeah
uh yousef what you got
this is my latest
silly game
that
i've found myself getting addicted to
if you if you know me you'll know that
when i when i go through stressful
periods my
defense mechanism is to regress to a
simpler time in my life and get addicted
to some stupid little game on my phone
um so my previous terrible addiction was
mortal kombat
which i had to go cold turkey mortal
kombat mobile i should say which is just
like button mashing and i spent lots of
money on buying new souls and upgrading
the characters
this one
is cool it's much simpler it's much
nicer and i would recommend it it's not
a toxic addiction it's called water sort
puzzle
or
as i call it with with my partner tubes
and it's it's basically
a set of tubes with different color
paint in them
like different colors above the thing
and you have one empty tube and you have
to pour
bits of the colors into the empty tube
and rearrange them so that you have
each tube has a single color
and
it's just a very simple
but challenging puzzle
the great thing about this
is that
it's rate limited so you can't get
addicted to it and if you put your phone
on airplane mode you skip all the
adverts
why is it rate limited
because it's not the kind of thing that
you can just endlessly play
because
well i mean you could but it's not like
i feel like a lot of the more complex
games
like i don't know if you've you guys
played like
ps5 or something recently
where
it's changed so much in dynamic from
when back in our day when we play like
metal gear solid on like a ps1
where it's just actual gameplay and cut
scenes and it was quite wholesome
whereas now it feels like everything's
just micro transactions and just trying
to like tap into your dopamine it's not
really a game experience it's more of a
like how can they extract as much money
or keep you on the screen as long as
possible
and i feel like it's a bit of a toxic
trend in gaming whereas this is just
pure and good
old-fashioned water sort puzzle
so i i play i play a bit of war zone i
play better call of duty
and i i know what you mean about it
being like
i feel like they've really tapped into
the
like what what you get rewards from so
the way they'll tell you you've got to
kill the way that like various
notifications pop up is very like
like you wouldn't be able to go to sleep
after playing for an hour anxiety and
juicing yeah but horrible like i think
the amount of time you bring up games i
think you should just just get an xbox
and do it properly like just get
yourself the basic the basic xbox and
get some some proper like 4k games i
would pay to watch you stream warzone on
twitch just [ __ ] talking people on it i
just put their heads i bet you'd be
really good at it
i think the reason i keep it at arm's
length is because i know that i would
get addicted to it right and
whereas uh
so have you heard of waze i know video
guy dean likes ways yes which is a a map
app no it's a it's a it's an advertising
platform that is masquerading as a man
yeah and it's it's terrible like it's
been designed by satan himself like
prince of darkness like it's just this
like
it's like gamified so you you'll drive
two miles and i'd be like
you have driven two miles successfully
you've gained ten ways points like
you've driven past three petrol stages i
don't care just tell me where it also
tries it it'll have a banner pop down
from the top and say there's a starbucks
on route do you want a coffee press here
to detour to this starbucks and
presumably while you're driving yes
yeah wild man that's that there is there
are certain apps that i think should be
faraday caged from advertising
and
map apps
are absolutely
one of them they need to be sacred don't
they correct correct right we'll do one
more and then we'll do a little bit of a
little bit of netflix some telly um
what have i got i've got some
unbelievable i'm gonna keep that for the
next time here's one that i learned the
other day uh push your tongue against
the roof of your mouth to stop you from
sneezing
so i've always wondered how you can stop
yourself from sneezing in a robust way
uh and i was testing this out because i
tweaked my back a couple of days ago and
i didn't want to sneeze too hard because
it would make my back hurt uh and i
remember reading this a long time ago
and uh yeah it works so you just have to
push really really hard against the roof
of your mouth
completely kills the desire to sneeze
it's the the plight of someone who's had
back problems that no one else will ever
understand is you feel a sneeze coming
in
the other thing if you can't stop it is
you try and position yourself like into
something with your head on a wall
you're like
[Music]
uh but
turning against roof of your mouth stops
you from sitting really the worst time
for me is when i'm like walking upstairs
with a coffee and i feel the sneeze
coming
yeah your head goes down and the cup
goes up and you're trying to like
trash
it's a problem that's worse for you
because you're so fast twitch and your
your top end strength is so high
that like what was it you said the other
day um
you are you were coughing or being sick
and you had real doms from it
uh
certainly if i'm
like if i'm if i ever throw up so like
normally if i'm if i've had too much to
drink
and i went silly and i end up spending
like the morning throwing up for a long
period of time
that is doms for days because there's
just so much ab that's being the thing
the worst thing is when i like when it's
slippy and i slip on ice
that that's fine it's the correction so
i'll
violently correct in the other way and
i'll like pull an oblique or
like or end up actually falling over
because of the correction
so if i just done nothing i'd have
slipped a bit and it would have been
fine but they're like and they're like
that's it i'm on the side
so okay uh what have we all been
watching recently what's been good
so
i'll go then shall we um
the do you remember when
we were at yours chris and we watched a
programme about
theranos yes elizabeth holmes
so there is a series
a dramatized series out about that same
story called the dropout
and it is really good
really really good
and it's very interesting as well having
like seen the documentary like seeing
the real story and then see the the
dramatization of it
that elizabeth
story is yeah it's been there's been a
ton of different good ones jake tran on
youtube's done a couple of good ones
amazon prime had that good documentary
but it's the same as the wework thing we
were the wework story which has just had
jared leto i think is the uh what's it
called like we
we fail i think or like we
i can't i don't know what i mean yeah
yeah that had been picked up by tons and
tons of youtubers first
right and that story and you watched
that and now you get to see jared leto
play
the role of adam whatever his face is
the dude that's sunning himself on an
island with half a billion of
i watch money that um like the
documentary about that on the plane on
the way back from san francisco like the
true
like the documentary version like of
what actually happened i had no idea
wild isn't it insane and these we works
are still all over the place just you
know losing money
yeah made it made it
a landlord like a real estate company
masquerading as a tech company
yeah and then exited fair play the
dropout okay cool uh yusef have you
watched anything from this century i
have actually okay so i think i think
these are recommendations from you guys
last time but
nine perfect strangers
three perfect strangers
it's nine or twelve it's about like a
period where they are the nicole kidman
thing yeah oh no it's different to what
is it yeah it's an amazing prime
original
i think
yeah there is an old film called
something perfect strange isn't it like
a courtroom
but
what was the one about the three the
triplets that got separated at birth oh
i think that's called three perfect
strangers yes
i think they just come inside me that
was excellent as well okay so what are
you watching
so i'm currently watching succession
from johnny's recommendation
unbelievable i finished it unbelievable
three seasons nailed it so good it's
yeah it is good i'm still early-ish in
it but um just a soundtrack
yeah great soundtrack not what i
expected um but then also the the guy
from there is in the big short and yes
i'm watching it it's the same director
uh that makes sense yeah
yeah it's so slick like the writing
the
dialogue the characters who's your
favorite character in it the guy who
abuses furniture
roman roma it's kind of roman he's just
an absolute like sexual deviant and just
like the way he just always like doesn't
sit on furniture properly and he's got
weird hair and i feel like so it at the
minute they're just building the
characters and i can just feel like it's
all gonna getting worse and worse yeah
yeah i really like tom
i just think the way he deals with
situations that he's put in
like especially in like the the latter
uh seasons you still feel he he's so
funny his reaction is like really
serious things yeah well
something that you have as a
well you say like a weakness or a
vulnerability you're very
seduced by a guy
that just deals with an ass [ __ ] from
life and just continues moving through
it that's why you like thingy and ozark
yeah precisely yeah that's true so like
um
what's it marty bird and ozark um
he just stays so analytical and calm
but you're absolutely right i didn't
even know that about myself welcome is
it malcolm tucker in
malcolm tucker does not stay cool at all
he loses his [ __ ] all the time yeah um
so i watched tinder swindle is a little
bit old now i guess um but bad vegan
which was like oh it's the tinder
swindler of the other thing and
crystalia had the best take on both of
those
tinder swindler
maybe you go well the guy was being sort
of quite
manipulative and stuff like that but
then bad vegan if anybody's watched that
it's just a woman who's
been
this guy who slowly got fatter
throughout the entire series managed to
get her to send him two and a half
million dollars
promised her that he was going to be
able to keep his keep her dog alive for
the rest of time said that he was like
some holy warrior fighting a war between
immortal people and delia [ __ ] nailed
it and he's like why don't we just
cancel naming all of these shows and
just create a series called gullible
[ __ ] because that's all that it's
about it's just about
who at what point do you say
you are
accountable for the fact that you
thought your dog was going to live
forever and you transferred someone 2.5
million
it's amazing that they had 2.5 million
like because they got to the stage in
their life where they've got oh no she's
kept on taking loans out this stuff the
people from her like super successful
vegan restaurant weren't being paid uh
and then he managed to get himself
written into the directorship ownership
thing and then she was written up and
this is all while they're still in a
relationship then he gets in contact
with her mother and gets her mother to
send him like a few hundred thousand as
well separately so this guy's obviously
a skilled manipulator but
gullible [ __ ]
so
speaking of which i've been listening to
a true crime podcast series it's a seven
part series called sweet bobby
and it's it could be in that that series
it's basically
someone who gets catfished but
catfished so hard like right up the
wazoo like it's not even
it it's just ridiculous and as you as
you're listening to it each episode
she's like oh my god this is even more
ridiculous than i could have
anticipated
um each episode is like half an hour
very good piece of journalism worth
worth having
to
yeah
um
also a bit of a life hack fail because i
i've now started in my list of
recommended tv shows and things that
people send me i've started putting the
name of the person who recommended it so
that they're accountable and i know how
to come back to them and say it was good
or bad
but
i didn't specify whether it was a tv
series or a film
so some i had the word safe recommended
and i don't know if it's the film safe
with jason statham
or
the series safe with the guy who played
daxter
it'll be the latter it looks like me
recommend
which one was better
i liked the film
because i was quite ill at the time i
had just fevers and it was just like a
nice like switch your brain off to jason
state and beating up some russians um
but the the series was uh
it felt like i was just being played
because it was just netflix like opening
up a bunch of like red herrings and open
loops and
oh what about this mystery oh what about
the him or maybe the butler did it and
then you get to the end and you're like
oh
she didn't like the series then
not fun no i felt like i was being
manipulated yeah
fair enough uh right we'll do one more
round johnny you got anything else that
you've been watching have i have i
mentioned the alpenist
before i don't think i will have done i
might have mentioned it to you both
individually but not on a life hacks
episode
is that fair i did mention it
individually
so the alpenist is
similar to free solo
have you both seen free solo yes yeah
total psychopath yeah so this this is
even this is even more hard hitting for
lots of various reasons so it opens with
uh
alex honnell on tim ferriss's podcast
and tim ferriss saying
who are you most impressed by at the
moment
and he says oh there's this guy
who's insane he and then it like cuts
and then the right then the film starts
and it's all about this guy who
basically does free solo but in like
ice with ice picks up mountains that
it's not rock a lot of the time and
sometimes you'll go from ice to stone
climbing back to ice again
and uh it has a sad ending
so
be prepared for the sad ending what a i
mean a hell of a film out of the film
very uh but quite like you don't like
come away from it feeling good but it's
very interesting yeah the alpinist okay
cool i've just i've got one more if you
don't mind yeah yeah yeah you chris i've
just spent a fair bit of time trying to
spell the word alpinist uh and before i
ended up on the correct spelling i've
actually gone to alpen like the
breakfast the cereal like as if there
was a man who was a specialist in alpen
in alpine yeah he's not that and that's
alpine's surprisingly not mentioned
throughout the entire film surprising
okay uh seth
a film called boiling point with
the who's that liverpool actor so i've
actually i've got a boner pick with you
about this but i'll let you uh i'll let
you say a piece okay it's chris i'll
enjoy this he's a he's an actor who's
from liverpool he just plays the typical
like liverpool guy like
oh what is it called
stephen graham stephen graham thank you
yeah he's every scouser in every film
stephen yeah yeah
exactly
so it's a film about a restaurant
kitchen that's on opening night
and they get visited by food standards
agency and they get downgraded from a
five to a three and then they have the
opening night and there's someone with
an allergy and then the the waitress
comes and he's like right this person's
got an allergy table 14 or is it on a
system no why isn't it on the system
guys if you if you have knowledge you
need to be on the system right okay
what's the allergy to and it's just like
very
stressful and it's all filmed in one
shot and that adds to the stress
especially for you and i for especially
for us because we
we are we see behind the fourth wall we
we recognize how much
could go wrong in a production and
so it's entirely like just a handheld
camera 90 minutes all done
the whole thing's in one shot you feel
stressed for the like cameraman and the
sound man oh my god and like you get to
the end and you just feel like you've
done a a busy shift in the restaurant i
got stressed with what was it
uh 1914
oh yeah you mentioned this
17. 1917 sorry it was shot in
uh like five shots the entire movie was
done in
huge huge huge long sequences
1917 12 or one isn't it yeah 1917. yeah
um what's your what's your bone to pick
with boiling point johnny
so
um you have recommended the film
it came on to
whatever it was on netflix amazon prime
or whatever and i was like saying
tobacco like oh you know easter frey
recommends films it's got stephen gray
man it gets really good ratings we
should watch it
so we're watching it it is really good
and as you have alluded to about a third
of the way in
a lady comes into the restaurant says
like i've got an analogy
[Laughter]
interesting that jesus recommended that
i hope nothing goes wrong
um and they accidentally
put nuts in her food
and she ends up being taken away from
the hospital in an ambulance
and i thought like is he sort of trying
to like
say something to me with this i think
it's a low-key threat against you
it's just because she didn't
do the hands thing
there we are
luckily i think it was walnut
so
we would have got out pine nuts are you
okay with pine nuts
i don't think they're enough that's the
thing isn't it
but then peanuts are a legume
peas how are you with peas peas are fine
okay
does anyone have an allergy to peas
i would assume so yeah someone's got an
allergy to everything
the the weirdest question you get asked
when you say i have an analogy is how
serious is the allergy
i would like to know what they intend to
do with that piece of information
so yeah it it seems weird for
the
restaurant staff to ask that because
like well you're not going to be
treating it anyway like
i think it's reasonable for a doctor to
ask that because that determines the
algorithm but by that by that point i'm
like it doesn't matter does it because
i've reacted yeah but it's like do you
give him piriton or do you have a
trouble
um
but you're right like for a restaurant
either what are you gonna do if it is
yeah either there's nuts in the food
there's no nuts in the food let's just
get clear on that fact
let you let me worry about how severe my
allergy is
it's a bit of an insult isn't it as a
question yeah
i don't mean like i get a bit of a dicky
tummy if i eat nuts like i i mean i have
it's not a taste preference
it's a serious medical condition i need
to hold your hand while i'm talking
about it yeah very serious look we've
done it gentlemen thank you very much if
people want to get some macros or get
help with starting their online business
where should they go
propanefitness.com forward slash
calculator if you want some macros if
you want to learn how we run propane
fitness and how to build an online
business it's probiofitness.com forward
slash modern wisdom
thank you gentlemen i appreciate you i
will see you soon i miss you both bye
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace